Hi everyone, my name is Sean Spitzer,
Senior Instructor for Epic Games.
In this group of lessons,
we're gonna be taking a look at materials,
masking, and material functions.
This essentially is a deep dive
into understanding materials better
and having a better control over them.
We're first gonna take a look at how to work
with materials and expand their functionality
to make them a bit more robust.
Later, we'll look at masking
and the different types of masking techniques.
And eventually we'll take a look at material functions
to introduce you how to craft a material function
and how to navigate and edit those assets.
So let's get started.